As a leader of a team, our business has
decided to terminate one of my people.
I disagree with their logic, but I'm not
in a position to change the decision.
What should I do to retain my influence
to support the rest of my team yet not
compromise my values? That's a good
question. That's a solid question.
That's a tough question.
It's a little bit tricky without the
details of the situation. But you know, I,
I wonder what kind of relationship that
did the person that asks a question,
I wonder what kind of relationship you
have with the senior leadership that
makes those decisions.
Cause you got to remember that our goal
is to always have the relationships up
the chain of command so that you
can influence those decisions.
And if you have that kind of relationship,
then you can find out why
that decision got made.
And there might be things
that you didn't know about,
some kind of strategic outcome that the
decision has had an out packed an impact
on. Right? So if you didn't know it,
but this guy had some kind of criminal
situation going on and you didn't know it,
then they can't talk about it cause he's
in legal cases. Okay. If you don't know,
don't speculate,
just go and ask.
And then you can take whatever those
reasons are and you can articulate them.
You know, down the chain of
command. And again, you want to,
you want to ask this question in a smart
way, university, why did bill get fired?
Hey, why did bill get fired?
No, you at, hey, you know,
from my perspective it seemed
like bill was doing a good job.
I want to kind of understand what you
were seeing so that I can lead people
better. If there's anything
that I could make up for,
I want to make sure I'm leading. You
know, like all those things you want to,
you want to help their ego and make
them feel good and make them feel like
you're on board with the program and not
make them feel like you're going there
and questioning their call because
that's just an attack on their ego.
So this is all these things. It's a
basic things, right? The fundamental,
he called it basic. These are the
fundamental things, right? This is the,
this is the way it is standard.
I should just say standard.
That's what I should
say. Standard stuff. You,
you're trying to build a relationship.
You don't want to go in but
your head up against their ego.
Then they get more defensive and next
thing you know they're going to fire
another one of your guys on
your team just to prove a point.
You can get yourself, you can dig yourself
that hole. But if you make your goal,
Hey, I'm going to build the
relationship with my boss,
that's what you are trying to do.
Now
if you find out why, then
you can articulate that to
the rest of the team and,
and the way that you maintain your values
is by maintaining your values. Okay,
so just because there's a situation
that a decision that gets made that you
don't agree with doesn't mean
that you compromise your values.
Like your boss can make a decision and
that does that, that you don't agree with.
That doesn't mean that your values are
compromised unless it's like an illegal
or it's an immoral or unethical situation,
which by the way of firing could
be one of those things, right?
The guy could be firing because he wasn't,
you know what wouldn't hae,
he wouldn't give me the
keys to the vehicle for the
weekend so I could use it on
my private time and I'm going to fire
him now, like that's unethical, right?
There's a problem there. So now your
values, definitely if you just silent Lee,
you're kind of compromising your values.
So there are times when you may have
to stand up, but bosses make decisions.
That's what they do and we do
our best to influence them.
Now if they decide something
we don't like, then yes,
we ask why and if we don't like it,
their explanation,
then we try and explain our case.
We try and explain why we thought
bill should have been not been fired.
Now you're not always going to be right.
You're not always going to be right.
And let me tell you something else.
Don't argue about six and one half dozen.
The other bill might've been on the
fence and they decided, you know what,
we've had enough trouble with bill.
We're getting rid of them.
And maybe there's valid reasons
why bill should have said,
but it's like it could have gone 60 40.
Are you going to put your reputation and
your relationship with your boss on the
line for over that little thing.
Now again,
I understand firing people is a big deal.
It's not small. It's not a little thing.
Especially you have a good relationship.
He's on your team, he's got kids,
you know, like all these things are there.
So what are you going to do about it?
Are you going to break down and,
and negatively impact your relationship
with your boss over this so that in the
future you have even less influence.
What happens when they go to fire Mike
and you haven't, and all you did was go,
hey, why'd you do this? This was stupid.
They're going to fire Mike and they're
not gonna listen to a damn thing.
You said you want to build a
relationship with them. Um,
you can,
you can explain what your viewpoint is.
And what you would have done.
Now this is like doubt.
This is talking to your team.
You can explain what your viewpoint
was and what you would have done,
but you also, you don't want to, you don't
want to, you want to be gentle, right?
As long as you explain,
if you explain that, hey,
I would've done something different.
And you also explained that the boss,
it was a tough decision and the boss made
the call and that the best thing that
we can do as a team is support the boss
so we can garner more influence over
these situations in the future.
That's good.
Yeah.
And you know what,
one of the best things you could do here
with your team is you can even explain
that it's your fault. The decision
got made, right? You say, look,
I haven't built a good enough
relationship with the boss.
That's why he fired bill. I'm working
on it. I'm going to do it better.
We're going to give them the support
that he needs so we can stop this thing
from half of this type of thing
from happening in the future.
So you don't want to throw your
boss under the bus. It's much,
much better to take ownership
of it all day, all day.
If you throw your boss under the bus and
you create an antagonistic relationship,
it's bad for you.
It's bad for your boss and it's bad for
your team and it's bad for your whole
organization.
I get it.
And there's a dichotomy here because if
your boss totally fired someone with not
good reason and it was a great guy,
and if you just jump on board with a boss,
you're going to look weak. So do
you have to balance that? Yes.
You have to be honest with your people.
You have to explain what's going on.
And that's why I think taking ownership
is one of the best things to do.
Your boss does something that's
totally out of line. Hey look,
here's what the boss did.
This is my fault and here's
what I'm gonna do to fix it.
I'm gonna build a better relationship.
I'm going to get more influence.
That's what I need to do.
I obviously let you guys down.
I'm not going to let it happen again.
That brings your team closer to you.
Yeah.
Rather than saying, Hey, the boss
was Boston idiot, he doesn't get it.
You gotta be, people don't actually
even respect that, by the way.
They don't actually even respect that.
Yeah. I'm not saying they say, hey,
that's the boss's decision, and that's,
you know what? We just support the boss.
I'm not saying that it's a dichotomy.
It's a balance that you have to,
you have to carefully walk,
compromise,
compromise on decisions and directions
in plants doesn't hurt. You know,
he's talking about compromising.
It's like you compromise is okay.
That's what it is. It's
compromise. Okay. Again,
as long as you're not compromising
your personal values, your ethics,
but compromising about a decision.
That's the way the world works.
Don't let your ego get into it.
Don't let your ego, so keep building,
keep building relationships.
Take ownership of the
decisions and support the team.
Keep building relationships,
not just up the chain of command,
but down so that you can
bring it all to gather.